[Music]
hey guys hallie here and as et's
resident lifestyle expert you know i've
got your back when it comes to the
hottest food trends and i'm here to tell
you overnight oats are having a real
moment people it's like oatmeal had a
glow up now i'm putting my spin on it
marrying two breakfast staples french
toast but make it overnight oats
yeah
you heard me french toast overnight oats
made with planet oat oat milk not only
is it totally yummy and super easy to
make it's also like a lighter twist on
your favorite sunday brunch
plus it's vegan and because i'm using
planet oat original oat milk it's super
rich and creamy and it'll have you going
back for seconds guaranteed honestly
it's like a nice warm hug
intrigued
let's get started
you'll need two cups rolled oats one to
two bananas all mashed up one teaspoon
cinnamon one teaspoon vanilla extract
two tablespoons maple syrup two
tablespoons chia seeds one and a half
cups planted out original oat milk and
to garnish a little more maple syrup and
your favorite fruit
okay
ready to be wowed because it doesn't get
faster or easier than this
combine all your ingredients in a bowl
except for the fruit
then mix it well cover it with plastic
wrap and throw it in the fridge
overnight
yeah i told you guys it was easy now all
you have to do is take it out of the
fridge when you're ready to eat then
spoon the oats into individual jars or
bowls but if you prefer it hot just pop
it in the microwave for 30 seconds then
add fruit and syrup
sit back indulge and be mad impressed
with yourself
[Music]